Ok
Auf geht's
Ich hoffe Twitch checkt heute relativ schnell dass das Stream on ist
Exquisite
so
Heute aber richtig big brain zeug massive brain alter
Heute explodiert das. Heute gibt es nicht nur EQ++ für jeden Prime-Sub sondern EQ++, also IQ sharp quasi
Pro Prime-Sub auch Pro normalem Sub
Weil heute ist richtig massive brain gefragt dass das funktioniert also ich weiß nicht ob es funktioniert ich hoffe mal dass das funktioniert. Von der Idee her sollte es funktionieren
Ich erzähl gleich was ich meine ich bin ein bisschen im arsch aber ich will das heute unbedingt ausprobieren
Ich bin so ein bisschen ein bisschen im arsch weil wie gesagt ganz normal bis 16 uhr gearbeitet
Dann war ich heute im garten hab zeug gemacht aber ich hab keine bock ich hasse gartenarbeit aller gartenarbeit ist das schlimmste
Habe ich eine stunde sport gemacht und dann habe ich noch ein bisschen weiter rumgebaut ich habe sogar hier oben wieder auf also ich
War wirklich echt beschäftigt mehr oder weniger jetzt bis 19 uhr ich habe jetzt schnell was gefuttert und
Hab jetzt stream an gemacht ja also
Ich war den ganzen tag beschäftigt bis jetzt ich bin übelst kaputt mir tun sogar schon die waden weh vom hin und her laufen
Aber trotzdem das will ich heute ausprobieren
Richtig poggers ich mache ich gehe mal kurz zu amazon und zeige euch das aber erst mal muss twitch mitbekommen haben dass es überhaupt
ist
Smart-Walve
So was hier da ist glaube ich ein video dabei wie es dann aussieht am endeffekt
Kann ich euch gleich zeigen
Es war war ein reveal ja genau
Also twitch hat noch nicht gecheckt dass das stream on ist
Sind gerade fünf zuschauer massiv
Oder besser gesagt nicht so nahe ist je nachdem ich muss noch kurz warten bis twitch das gecheckt hat
Rosario hast du hast hast du den stream so gefunden oder wie hast du mitbekommen dass der on ist weil email benachrichtigungen sind nicht da und
und discord benachrichtigungen sind bestimmt auch noch nicht da und
Notifications an sich auch nicht
Also wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich hat es doch nicht tue nicht kann er den du folgst auf der linken seite das ja ok
Ja muss ich muss ich mal warten muss ich mal warten bis twitch das gecheckt hat dass der stream on ist
Dauert ja dauert ja manchmal ein bisschen bis das da ist
Das ist denn ist das alles richtig da
Ja das sieht aus wie immer
Kappa klaus kappa klaus ah jetzt hat's twitch glaube ich gecheckt jetzt kommen die ersten leute
Streamception
Jetzt jetzt hat's twitch jetzt guck mal jetzt kommen sie jetzt hat's twitch gecheckt jetzt ist kein intimer chat mehr kappa klaus
Jetzt hat's twitch gecheckt dass das on ist
Ja das hat drei minuten gebraucht hier
zu
Hey max ich habe einen grunden wo zwei gesellschaft der stress haben und der einer ist der mein ich führe daten ab was was
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht dein problem die sollen sich eigentlich werden
So also ich warte jetzt noch mal kurz fünf minuten bis das streben alles richtig on ist und dann zeige ich euch was wir vorhaben
Weil ich sage euch heute ist massiv gehirn gefragt
Co steht ich weiß für das steht was meinst du was meinst du warum ich das sag
Mir ist schon klar was das heißt
Das hat man früher in mmos gesagt und generell in chats ist glaube ich heute nicht mal angesagt
Übrigens habt ihr es mitbekommen cringe ist jugendwort des jahres geworden und was habe ich gesagt was jugendwort des jahres wird
Oder was habe ich gesagt was ich mir wünschen würde was jugendwort des jahres wird
Richtig cringe und cringe hat gewonnen die haben bestimmt mein stream geguckt
Die haben bestimmt geguckt ah der wubblos
Der hat gesagt das soll cringe werden ja dann wird das auch cringe
Ne mittwoch mittwoch ist zweiter platz gewesen cringe ist auf platz eins
Bald ist wieder kappa klaus dauert bloß noch zwei monate
Verstandsbewusstsein
Was stand zur auswahl keine ahnung weißt du mal soll ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz was wir machen und zwar ich habe mir was gekauft
Ich habe mir was gekauft und zwar habe ich mir gekauft eine smart water wealth
Wi-Fi control shut off wealth
kompatibel with alexa google automatic voice control remote control bluetooth control for kitchen garden farm black
Ganz wichtig also der komplette titel ist hier ausschlaggebend ja
Das ist ein typischer china chinesen amazon titel so ich habe mir so ein teil gekauft
Was das was das kann
Was das kann also kann ich euch gleich zeigen hier aber da liegt nämlich
Ich zeige euch mal ein video von einem der das ganze schon an einem rohr dran hat so was so was habe ich gekauft
Stimmt es das wslg unter kann schon sein weiß ich nicht so so sieht das aus
So und dann macht man das hier dran guckt das kommt dann so dran an den hebel in dem fall an wasserhahn
Und dann drückst du auf den knopf
gaben approved genau
Oder aber du machst über die app oder aber wir flaschen das ganze ding was nicht so einfach ist heute
Auf kollege drückt den knopf drück den knopf und dann seht ihr dann legt es den hebel um
So
So ist es gedacht
Also so so sollte das funktionieren und ich habe das ich habe das teil hier liegen ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen guck da ist es
Achtung hand reveal. Oh ein bisschen lag bisschen lag was ist hier los?
Naja
Kaum lag fast ein bisschen lag
Aber nicht viel naja gut also ich habe das teil hier liegen
Ich muss mich muss man übrigens ein bisschen mal nicht so nicht so hektisch mal ein bisschen langsamer wie gesagt war der ganze tag hier am start
Also ich habe das teil hier liegen und ich würde sagen wir schließen das jetzt mal an
Leider ich hatte es schon mal auf ich habe mal kurz reingeguckt vorhin
Leider haben wir ein problem
Die dinger wurden früher
Mit dem esp 866 ausgeliefert. Mittlerweile haben die irgendeinen komischen Realtek chip drauf
Das kann man nicht so einfach flaschen das heißt wir müssen den chip ausbauen und in esp
32 oder esp 866 einbauen
Da bin ich gespannt ob das funktioniert
Theoretisch sollte das funktionieren
Ich habe mich da im vorfeld schon mal schlau gemacht aber vielleicht ist das ding danach im arsch wir gucken jetzt übrigens erst mal ob das an sich
Funktioniert das ganze teil hier
So da ist nämlich da ist nämlich ein netzteil dabei das ist 12 volt braucht das ding hier guck da steht es irgendwo da
12 volt ac
12 volt dc
12 volt dc ein amper netzteil das war dran haben sie hier auch dabei so ein billig billig china netzteil
Zum glück eu stecker und ich kokona
Mal kurz das gehäuse in die ecke pfeffern
exzellent
So jetzt probieren wir mal aus ob das prinzipiell im originalzustand überhaupt funktioniert weil ich habe kein bock
Das umzubauen und festzustellen das funktioniert nicht und dann zurückzubauen im originalzustand funktioniert auch nicht
Das funktioniert nicht und dann zurückzubauen im originalzustand funktioniert es auch nicht
Haben wir das mal auf
Habt ihr auch manchmal so problemen diese komischen kabeldinger aufzukriegen mal in die eine richtung mal in die andere richtung funktioniert meist nicht auf aneb
So also ich stöpsel das mal ein
Stöpsel das mal hier ein so und von der theorie her
Oh das hat sich gerade bewegt ein bisschen schäpp oder ist das nicht ein bisschen schäpp
standardmäßig guckt mal
zu sich
schäppschämpf
das ist schräg
Leute ist es brauchen
Das funktioniert im auslieferungszustand schon nicht
Genial na das ist ja toll
Hä hängt das hängt das irgendwie guckt mal
Ist das moment moment ist das zu fest geschraubt vielleicht
Ich habe ich habe hier den passenden übrigens die china chinesen weil wir da so schlau haben das genauso gemacht
Dass das hier nicht drauf passt
Du musst das hier nicht drauf passen
So jetzt noch mal probieren vielleicht war das zu fest das ist broken das ist ripp
Das ist ripp
Muss man das entriegeln oder so
Das ist jetzt schon kaputt
Macht man damit was ist das
Das ist das ist broken das ist jetzt schon kaputt das china chinesen kram
Okay, wir gucken mal rein wir gucken uns mal das wahnsinnig geniale handbuch an wenn ich es finde
Was dazu steht hier
excellent handbuch
Mehr gibt es nicht mehr gibt es nicht also handbuch. Ah jetzt alles klar
Ja, es laggt warum laggt das
How to install fix mounting bracket
Da muss man nichts machen für das muss einfach so funktionieren du hast das hemmt selbe hemmt aber ich exquisite hemmt
Goethe straße louis vitor store zahlt die kollektion bar fick auf sponsor
So ich schraube das jetzt mal ab weil ich habe irgendwie das dofe gefühl das ist broken
Das habe ich vorhin drauf geschraubt dass ich meine das muss man drauf schrauben laut handbuch auch
Also es geht kaum ab
Gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
Ackmann ist es
Es könnte aber auch sein dass ich das einfach immer ausschalten, aber dann sollte es normalerweise mit einem knopfdruck eigentlich funktionieren
Das ist broken broken af das teil ok da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
Man legte der ring ist eine art notentriegelung ja gibt es ja nicht wirklich was zu entriegeln
Tja ich würde sagen wir schrauben das jetzt einfach mal auf und gucken
Wir schrauben das jetzt wir schrauben das jetzt einfach mal auf und gucken was soll man sonst machen also wenn es jetzt direkt
Broken ist wäre natürlich schon echt fail ich habe nichts gemacht mit dem ding ich habe die schrauben unten rausgemacht
Und habe festgestellt es ist kein esp und hab wieder zugemacht habe nichts gemacht also ich das ist jetzt legit das erste mal dass ich
Da drauf gedrückt habe ich habe also ich weiß wirklich nicht ob es funktioniert keine ahnung
So aber das wäre ganz schön kacke wenn es schon prickt angekommen wäre
Sollen wir kurz ärmel hoch krempeln wir machen das jetzt einfach mal auf und gucken rein da kann ich euch auch gleich zeigen
Ich wollte ich wollte das mal eigentlich wollte ich vorher noch ein paar dinger machen aber
Egal
Erstmal wir müssen erst mal gucken dass es im dass es im auslieferungszustand wenigstens funktioniert oder
Mal gucken was für china chinesen schrauben wir haben ganz normale
Ja ich mach das mal ich mach das mal auf kamera auf das geht nämlich schneller als wenn ich das vor die kamera halte
Nicht wegfliegen
Ich hoffe ich ist das nicht kaputt das wäre ja mal richtiger painstab na gut es ist amazon dann kann ich es einfach wieder zurückschicken aber
Ja warum ist das pro was soll das
Das wäre es jetzt wenn das ding schon im auslieferungszustand kaputt mehr meine güte
Da habe ich jetzt ja bock drauf so das schöne ist also so sieht das teil aus ist ist äußerst übersichtlich wofür
Wir das ventil verwendet wasserzufuhr zur heizung
Muss man ab und zu mal auf aufdrehen und bisschen druck wieder reinzukriegen das
So also muss man so alle zwei drei monate mal in keller und dafür wollte ich das hier verwenden naja also viel ist es nett ihr sehts
Aber ist das ein bisschen schäpp guckt mal
Aber man erkennt es jetzt nicht richtig aber die zahnräder die so richtig aneinander sind
Was auch immer was auch immer wie passt da ein esp rein hier guck
Das ist aber kein esp das ist das also jetzt zeige ich euch mal das problem
Das hier müssen wir flaschen das ding mit custom firmware das problem ist das ist kein esp den können wir nicht mit custom firmware flaschen
Das heißt den müssen wir ablöten oder oder ab heiß heiß lüftern
Und dann machen wir testweise mal irgendwie so ein teil hier dran
Man eigentlich eigentlich könnte man nur diesen chip hier drauf machen aber
Wozu zum ausprobieren das ding das ding kriege ich da im zweifelsfall auch noch neben rein irgendwie
Aber es muss erst mal funktionen okay gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert im
Hier im aufgebauten zustand gucken wir mal ob sichs dreht
Wo ist denn
Wo habe ich das netzteil hin
Chat wo ist das netzteil ich sehe es nicht hier ob ich das netzteil hin
Wer hat es wer hat es netzteil chat hier ich hab es hat das ventil eine rücklaufsperrkarte ja wahrscheinlich
Ja so also das hier ist ja kein das ist ja nicht wirklich das ist das der motor mit dem du das
Ventil auf und zu machen kannst mal gucken ob das jetzt geht
Was ist das denn warum geht es nicht
Und der knopf dreht es auch nicht
Das ist das ist ziemlich ich meine es könnte jetzt auch sein dass es einfach schon im am
Anschlag ist aber der der knopf sollte das eigentlich bewegen macht es aber nicht
Muss mit der app verbinden du meinst mit der app verbinden dass der knopf überhaupt funktioniert
Ne okay jolo wir machen wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen ich löte jetzt hier also passt mal auf
Ich löte jetzt hier den anschlüsse für den esp für den esp 266 dran aber vorher müssen wir
Pin layout gucken weil ich habe keine ahnung wo ich das dran löten soll ok müssen wir mal im
Internet suchen also wichtig ist was steht da drauf chat hier big brain time was heißt das
muss jetzt selbst mal in der kamera gucken wb3s ne ja wb3s ok ich muss jetzt gar nicht so tun ich
weiß dass es wb3s heißt weil ich habe vorher schon mal auf gehabt
aber du machst den alten controller weg na erstmal lasse ich den dran
also ich muss mal meine vm anmachen jetzt müssen wir uns aber erst mal pin layouts
raussuchen weil sonst wird das nix ja aus anmachen musiklautstärke passt das
nur wir müssen erst mal die pins raussuchen by the way ich ziehe das mal kurz in die vm um
dann wirst du vom alten controller gebankt ist das so wenn wir jetzt neu
warum ist das kein dark seam was da kaputt wie kann man das verwenden wie geht monka es ein dark
seam was da fack ist aber kann das zeug war ordentlich copy pasted so ok so das muss auf
den desktops dann muss es kleiner gemacht werden mal gucken wir müssen das setup kurz einstellen
hide controls und jetzt windows s jetzt state das da oben hallo hallo so und jetzt können wir mal
schauen also verwenden wir hier immer verwenden wir hier sonst chrome was verwenden wir normalerweise
firefox oder chrome weiß gar nicht war man normalerweise in der vm immer feines wahrscheinlich also
das war wie ist das ding w3 bs das motor gucken wir mal ne chat ihr habt doch bestimmt aufgepasst
wie ist das ding jetzt w3 8s w3 bs wb 3s wb 3s das motor ja das das habe ich nämlich im
vorfeld schon gesehen und zwar irgendein big brain typ bei das motor hat es ein esp hat die
pins von einem esp und dem wb 3s das ist ein realtek chip übrigens miteinander verglichen
und die pins sind oftmals an ähnlichen stellen aber nicht alle an der gleichen stelle deswegen
müssen wir uns erstmal die pin layouts dazu raussuchen also das ist der da drauf ist das
ist der die wir drauf machen wollen wobei drauf machen wollen zu viel gesagt ist ich löte ja nicht
das modul drauf ich mache da vier fünf kabel dran und stöpsel die dann an den d1 mini also
an an den da ich komme das hier in der hoffnung dass es dann funktioniert also wb 3s pin out das
habe ich nämlich gesehen dass es da was gibt genau guckt hier hat nämlich jemand als sehr netter
mensch hat esp pins verglichen mit wb 3s pins so das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal gucken
wo was hin muss das heißt ich mach mal groß das heißt also wenn das wenn das stimmt was der typ
da was der typ da gemalt hat ich mache mir das mal kurz auf dem zweiten monitor also wenn da stimmt
was der typ da gemalt hat dann heißt das ich brauche mal einen zettel ich brauche mal einen
zettel so also so rum ist das modul so rum ist das esp wobei das ist egal naja ich habe die pins
richtig beschriftet also wir malen jetzt mal wir malen jetzt mal mal gucken ob wir das irgendwie
was sinnvolles hinkriegen also von der idee her müsste das ja dann so sein also machen wir
hier irgendwie so eine kästchen so das hier ist irgendwie die wlan antenne so links oben links
oben müsste dann also das hier das hier ist also das ist von unten wir sehen den chip jetzt ja von
oben das heißt diese seiten das hier ist das hier das heißt es ist gespiegelt das bedeutet
links unten ist hier links oben was bedeuten würde was bedeuten würde das da ist ground
oben links und stift wo habe ich einen stift hier das heißt das hier wenn das wenn das
irgendwie sinn ergibt das heißt das hier oben ist ground spiegel ist dann einfach digital ach was
digitale spiegelung quer quate hast du kein multimeter doch das probieren wir danach aus also
das ist ground ok danach geht es weiter mit oft mit der anderen seite da ist 3,3 volt wenn ich das
richtig sehe hier das heißt die andere seite da ist bcc die zweiter dass die zwei reichen
erstmal schon da kann ich jetzt mal kann ich jetzt wirklich mal das multimeter nehmen und
gucken ob das stimmt also wenn das stimmt was der typ hier fotografiert hat und ich jetzt das
multimeter nehme dann sollte ich 3,3 volt kriegen wenn ich das hier oben dran halte gucken wir mal
guck mal mal wo ist es denn da probieren wir mal gespannt china übrigens hier china chinesen
multimeter billig aber funktioniert ganz gut so ja weiß ich erkennt man was ja aber erkennt
mir wunderbar wunderbar so ich versuchte es mal so zu drehen dass man das sieht das ist jetzt leider ein
bisschen klein wenn man nicht sicher ob ich da irgendwie ranzoomen kann oder so oder ob ich
vielleicht so machen kann das erkennt man alles nicht richtig na egal aber hier erkennt man es
gleich drauf das ist halt das ist halt ziemlich ziemlich klein und ich kann es ich kann es halt
auch nicht weiter runter machen weil da komme ich nicht mehr dazwischen also von der idee her wenn
das stimmt was wir hier auf rausgefunden haben dass das crown ist links oben und und das hier
wie sie sehen dann sollte ich das da jetzt dran halten und so dass ich irgendwie dran
komme und dann sollten da entweder fünf oder 3,3 volt stehen ich vermute mal 3,3 volt spiegel
multimod omg so schauen wir mal
das ist das broken ach ich habe den gar nicht am netzteil dran ach so sagt es doch einer null
nee wo ist das netzteil hier ich habe es gar nicht am netzteil der dann ist das funktioniert
wlan ja das sollte man erfinden wenn das einer erfinden kann er richtig viel kohle verdienen so
jetzt 3,3 excellent ok das stimmt was wir hier gemacht haben schon mal gut sehr gut also das
ist schon mal ground und wie sie sieht das bin ich ja schon mal froh dass das funktioniert was
der typ da aufgeschrieben hat so next geht jetzt der knopf eigentlich mittlerweile funktioniert
nicht tesla hat lampen so weiles betrieben ja das ist aber wahrscheinlich auf etwas nimmt
wahrscheinlich mit der entfernung ganz schön rapide ab oder aber du brauchst quadratisch mehr
so ok also ground wie sie sie was kommt als nächstes habe ich mein stift hin was kommt
was kommt als nächstes war doch mal ich mache mal so halbe halbe jetzt mal irgendwie sieht
hallo deck wie kriegst du das jetzt nebeneinander so excellent huge massive massive anordnungs
champ so gut so ok poggers also lupus oculus danke für den film zusammen das heißt hier
haben wir ground das bedeutet das ist die ecke das heißt als nächstes haben wir pwm
1 oh nee pwm 1 wirklich ernsthaft die werden doch nicht den motor mit pwm steuern anstatt
es einfach nur relay an und aus dann wird ok das dann das ist das ist abgefuckt dann
weiß ich nicht was ich da machen muss na egal also guck mal also das hier ist das nächste
ist dann quasi pwm 1 pwm 1 so das nächste ist dann txd also ja gut das ist zum flaschen
wahrscheinlich das brauche ich dann eh nix eh nicht txd1 und dann rxd2 brauche ich auch
nicht restes egal mehr ist nicht angeschlossen ich weiß ich ob ihr das seht guckt mal mehr
ist mehr ist mehr ist da nicht angeschlossen seht ihr das sind bloß zwei stück wenn man
das richtig erkennen würde jetzt bei natürlich poggers sind nur zwei stücke angeschlossen
und bei dem anderen sind bloß die oberen drei und dann unten irgendwas angeschlossen
was txd ach txd 2 ja tatsächlich so so da kommt wie sie sie kommt ob in der ecke danach
kommt pwm 0 sehe ich das richtig pwm 0 das über wie sie sie ist pwm 0 so dann ist der
nächste ist pwm 4 ich hoffe die machen da nicht wirklich pwm das wäre abfuck extrem
also pwm über über tazmota habe ich keinen bock was wir machen heute wirds massive brained
ich habe mir ein smartes ventil einen smarten ventilschalter gekauft und den will ich flaschen
mit tazmota das problem ist nur oder mit customfirma das problem ist nur dass dieses ding da
oben was du siehst dieses package ist kein esp das ist den realtech chip das heißt wir
löten den realtech chip ab und machen den esp dran und dann hoffen wir das alles noch
funktioniert so pwm 0 pwm 0 was kommt als nächstes pwm 4 pwm 4 dann kommt was pwm 5
der nächste ist was pwm 14 was auch immer pwm 14 ist guckt hier sind wir pwm 14 dann
kommt e n das brauchen wir bestimmt zum flaschen denke ich mal e n a d c 3 und hier unten haben
wir noch was was ist das gen zen zen was auch immer so das heißt das wichtige ist jetzt
erst mal dass wir das ding angeschlossen kriegen den esp 286 ground und vcc rest scheiß
erst mal drauf erst mal gucken dass wir den irgendwie zum laufen bekommen so deswegen
flaschen wir uns jetzt mal den d1 mini flaschen wir uns mal mit der aktuellen tazmota version
zen ja genau rützen ist doch ganz bestimmt sicherheit an amd kern ja ganz bestimmt also
wie gesagt das ist irgendein realtech angeblich das neue ok das heißt wir flaschen jetzt
mal ein esp ach ja was wir dazu brauchen ist der heimliche held des streams natürlich
wieder nämlich small access point da ist er mini access point haben problem der switch
point brauche aber strom am switch dass er funktioniert ja gut dann tja irgendwas muss
ich davon jetzt raus machen ma ma ma ma lüt lüt lüt stellt raus wobei ich brauche noch
gar kein zum flaschen brauche ich doch gar kein access point na doch wir müssen gucken
ob es funktioniert zumindest wir müssen zumindest gucken ob sich anmeldet das können wir schon
mal machen also auf genau nutzt doch den usb lüter ja genau das ding ist so dermaßen kacke
so switch ist an access point dran und jetzt braucht der access point noch strom und der
access point kriegt den strom über micro usb wenn wir alles richtig gemacht haben dann
sollte der jetzt leuchten der leuchtet auch man erkennt bloß nicht richtig und jetzt gucken
wir mal im browser auf den access point mikrotik ne es hat kein poe das ding also ist der switch
hat kein poe was hat das ding für eine ip das small access point muss ich mal kurz gucken
haben wir das ding nicht letztens irgendwie mal gepinkt oder so wenigstens 88 254 klingt
doch klingt das gut oder schlecht ja 2 2 1 3 hat er angeblich da ist er der access point
nice weiter könnte mir einen günstigen einfachen switch empfehlen für zwei raspberry pi laptops
hinter der fritzbox ja du kannst dir irgendeinen billigen also wenn es wirklich gar nichts
können soll irgendeinen billigen tp link acht port auf amazon kaufen der ist noch mikrotik
ja ich glaube preisleistungsmäßig dürfte das von feature der der beste access point
der welt sein das ding hat ein vollständiges router us drauf kostet 20 euro und ist ein
access point so schweig nein fack cute access point doch mal gesäft save alda saved gut
ip dhcp server leases was ist das für einer active das motor es ergibt überhaupt keinen
sinn dass die steckdose eine list hat die steckdose ist überhaupt nicht abgeschlossen
die steckdose kann sich keine lease gezogen haben die steckdose ist nicht angeschlossen
vielleicht macht er das nach dem booten automatisch was auch immer egal wir flaschen jetzt wir
flaschen jetzt den d1 mini mit der aktuellen tas motor version und gucken ob das ich anmelden
kann am access point also wir machen das mal so wie die noobs das machen also die coolen
leute nehmen esp tool esp weis gar ja also die coolen leute nehmen esp tool aber die
noobs die nehmen tesmo taser mit tesmo also mit tesmo taser kann wirklich jeder esp flaschen
mit das motor das gar kein ding es hat sogar ein gui ich weiß bloß nicht wie man es unter
linux installiert wenn ich ehrlich bin heißen packages alles klar beim wein nee ich glaube
das hat probleme mit wein asmo taser 1ks cannot open shared object file anzeige ist raus warum
nicht but why ah kann das sein cute cereal dass es einfach nicht installiert ist an libraries
ja cereal libraries sind nicht installiert also ein so sein der pyson packet da geht
es geht doch hier der pyson package manager sagt schon ein bisschen so also da ist er
wird tas mutiert tas motor bin wollen wir haben release 10 ach gibt es version 10 habe
ich gar nicht gesagt wann gibt es denn seit wann gibt es denn version 10 ich dachte version
9 ist aktuell und den normen normen ist am start seit ach vor acht tagen ja das habe
ich nicht mitbekommen nicht mitbekommen normies out so was ist jetzt neue feature was kann
das neues ehrlich gesagt juckt es mich nicht soll es einfach flaschen und gut ist hip ist
richtig 3 hat so ich schließe den mal an und flasht den kurz dann seht ihr mal wie
easy das ist also einfach hier usb jetzt jetzt nicht weil ich stöpseln ist ein rechner dran
per usb hier d1 mini usb anschließend an rechner hängen und flaschen easy as fuck
fertig ist das kriegt wirklich jeder gebacken damit ist dran refresh erfindet nicht weil
ich nicht so vm connecte fringe irgendwie erkennt er den ich
nee nee nee ota vielleicht da ist ja nichts drauf ich muss mal kurz gucken ob der blink
beim anschließen
oh fuck der ist komplett ripp oder ich glaube das ding ist komplett hinüber seg das muss
ich jetzt mal ausprobieren da brauche nur ein bräuchte anderes usb kabel vielleicht
auch am usb kabel ich glaube der esp ist hinüber macht nichts wir haben ja noch andere ist
natürlich ein bisschen doof war ja normalerweise die led unten nee hier fringe
da ist komplett das komplett komplett das das komplett das da der d1 mini hier
der erkennt den und er erkennt noch nicht mal den das das serial okay das natürlich das sagt der
wäre jetzt echt praktisch gewesen so probieren wir mal anderen aus also der hier weiß ich das
allerdings in esp 32 jeder da der weiß ich dass er funktioniert den hatte ich nämlich schon mal
dran ah ja instant geht instant aber ich will eigentlich kann esp 32 verwenden hier guck erkennt
er sofort warum ist denn der kaputt ich meine das ding habe ich vorhin frisch ausgepackt das
ist china china ups china chinesen qualität alter guck mal ich habe das ding vorhin ausgepackt an
nämlich nicht der ist komplett frisch frisch aus der verpackung naja nämlich so ein das problem
ist den kriege ich garantiert nicht ins gehäuse rein ja was machen wir jetzt ich meine ich hab
noch so einen ganz billigen uralten esp 1 aber zu stark statisch aufgeladen hast du ich habe
bestimmt noch irgendwo welche aber die müsste ich jetzt erstmal suchen keine ahnung doch ich
habe garantiert ich weiß aber nicht wo okay das ist jetzt hat das macht mir jetzt ein
bisschen den strich durch die rechnung dass der d1 mini nicht funktioniert
der ist komplett hinüber da macht gar nix
der macht einfach nur gar nichts ist vielleicht so vielleicht auch nur die usb anschluss träge ich
tot ripp ist vorbei wird auch nicht warm oder so
der ist der ist dead ok ja schauen wir mal vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht wird man noch
ein ich glaube ich glaube ja nicht also ich glaube nicht dass ich hier noch ein drin habe
ich habe garantiert noch welche aber ich weiß nicht wo wir können wir können mal kurz gucken
ich war mal ich mach mal hier wir gucken mal die kiste zusammen an also als delivery
irgendwelche schüttel sensoren laura stells relay kram das ist zwar ein esp 266 aber halt
und fetter loops spannungsregler irgendwelche relays
spannungsverhandler innen das wifi module das hier könnte das hier könnte einer sein
nähe das ist ein powershield also ich ah ah mist nähe also ich fürchte hier ist tatsächlich
hier ist tatsächlich kein d1 mini mehr drin gut das ist natürlich dumm das ist richtig dumm
das haben wir hier das steht d1 mini drauf hier guckt mal das sind die esp 32 ja da nehme ich
halt in esp 32 aber da ist halt ein bisschen fetter da weiß ich ob der da reinpasst das
ärgert mich jetzt dass der kaputt ist jaja das habe ich gelesen dass f12 illegal ist
wo könnte ich noch ein d1 mini haben ich habe garantiert noch welche ich weiß nur nicht
wo ich gucke mal hier vielleicht habe ich hier noch irgendwie klebeband habe ich hier
noch irgendwas drin aha aha was ist das hier das ist auch noch esp 32 d1 mini mensch
ich gucke jetzt mal hier alles durch powershields powershields in massen aha
der hat leider pins dran der hat leider hallo kamera please der hat leider pins dran aber
den können wir trotzdem annehmen so was auch immer hierfür ganzes zeug rumfliegt alles
alles alles weg hier mal alles alles weg das zeug aber ich habe einen gefunden das so schnell
kann es gehen jetzt können flaschen demo band weg den da weg und den wieder ohne den tisch
hat geklingelt nicht geklingelt gut dann flaschen wir den hier jetzt mal mal gucken ob der hier
jetzt funktioniert achtung usb wenn der auch nicht funktioniert anscheinend am usb zu liegen
der geht instant hab das gehört wenn es jetzt auch liegen bleiben würde so win hang da ist
er da ist er er erkannt also machen wir quitsch starten wir nochmal neu gucken ob es erkannt
hat ja jetzt hat es jetzt hat es erkannt alles klar ok dann können wir jetzt test desmotisen
originalfirma ist egal bin release version 10 self resetting device erase before flash
spam desmotis auf gehts ja also den da den kann schon mal in müll
es ist es ist ein dot files repo aktuell so halbwegs also der kann schon mal in müll
ich mein es lohnt sich nicht die dinger großartig zu gucken ob man die nicht irgendwie reparieren
was meistens nicht geht die kosten ein euro oder so also es hält sich echt in grenzen
schickt schickt zurück nach china den habe ich gar nicht direkt aus china habe ich von
ads ads delivery also jetzt ist das ding geflasht jetzt kommt das motor hoch jetzt kann man
auch sagen send config ssid oh wie heißt das hier muss man mal im small access point gucken
äh wireless äh wie heißt denn jetzt das eigentlich home was habe ich denn für ein
password kann man das password eingeben pass secret ah wo stellt man hier das password ein
wo ist das password ok home 3 heißt es schon mal seht ihr wo man das password einstellt
secret vielleicht ok dann ist das irgendein big brain modus und ich hoffe mal dass es
dass ich checke ich glaube ich weiß ich glaube ich weiß das password warte mal ich hab das
ich hab das glaube ich hier in irgendeinem notepad sogar drinne stehen das müsste müsste
funktionieren ist safe send alles klar gucken wir mal ob sich das ding meldet per hallo ob
sich das ding meldet per dhcp ha da ist er guckt mal hier make static make static das
ist d1 mini gaben approved nice da ist er alles klar so dann gehen wir mal mal das motor drauf
ach das geht ja nicht muss ich erstmal die route adden mit root ging das so glaub schon
ich habe vergessen was muss man machen um war das nicht so ich bin wieder ich bin wieder
richtig pepega ich habe wieder keine ahnung wenn das funktioniert hat wieso moment ist
doch richtig er antwortet doch da sind wir das ist unser gefläch der esp gut dann können
wir den jetzt anschließen an das teil dahin in der ecke also das funktioniert 88 253 konsole
juckt mich nicht configuration main wir lassen erstmal alles standard ok also das motor ist
drauf können wir hier abmachen abmachen und weg damit da ist er so und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob wir das irgendwie hinbekommen also wie gesagt
das ist heute nicht das normale geflashe wir müssen den chip der nicht flaschbar ist austauschen
gegen irgendwas was flaschbar ist und dann müssen wir raus bekommen welche gp aus was
machen unser vorteil ist es gibt ein paar templates für diese diese ventil für diesen
ventil switch gibt es ein paar das motor templates als er noch esp basiert war das heißt die
haben sie wahrscheinlich nicht viel geändert denke ich mal hoffe ich mal so also auf geht's
will ich sagen wir müssen den kram jetzt irgendwie dran das ist auch übelst warm alter
ist der motor vielleicht blockiert ist der mo der motor ist über alter der motor ist
übertrieben heiß das stimmt doch was nicht der ist bestimmt blockiert oder sowas was
macht man mit diesem ring hier unten hat irgendjemand einen plan was man mit diesem komischen ring
hier unten macht
mal gucken ob er noch angeht er blinkt random
er versucht sich guckt mal der versucht sich zu drehen aber aber es klappt nicht das ding
ist broken ich glaube das ist echt kaputt der motor ist auch mega heiß
nee kräftig dran ziehen bringt nix also irgendwas ist hier broken irgendwas ist hier nicht richtig
meint ihr das ist normal guckt mal da ist so ein spalt unten sollte das nicht eher direkt
aufliegen und und ich meine die zahnräder das sieht ja okay aus aber das sollte bestimmt
direkt aufliegen weil guckt mal das zahnrad steht ja auch hier oben drüber raus ich glaube
das ding ist broken das ist kein esp das ist kein esp das ist ein realtech chip deswegen
funktioniert das nicht also was der pin hier machen soll ist mir komplett schleierhaft
wenn du den drehst dreht sich oben oder ansonsten geht nix mit der original software schau naja
das ist die original software und da funktioniert auch schon nicht und das ding wird mega heiß
also richtig brutal heiß der motor und das ist ja in der regel nur wenn das irgendwie
blockiert ist alter das ist der motor verbrennt die echt die finger das bestimmt 80 grad
heiß gerade woran könnte das liegen dass das dass es nicht geht also ich würde ja
darauf tippen dass das hier unten unten sein muss ich meine wir können trotzdem mal den
esp dran machen und gucken ob es funktioniert alter das ist mega heiß das ding ja was mache
ich denn da jetzt damit soll ich jetzt erst mal den esp dran machen erst mal gucken dass
der motor wieder läuft
generell fixen ja das problem ist ich habe ja keine ahnung wie es aussehen muss so wir
gucken jetzt noch mal in dieses super hilfreiche handbuch rein ob da irgendwas zu diesem pin
steht das handbuch ist komplett für den arsch da siehst du gar nichts drin das ist alles
mehr gibt es nicht dazu support clip was ist denn ein support clip wer supportet da wen
also fest dran ziehen fest dran ziehen bringt schon mal nix das ist das ding ja aber richtig
also ich habe das doofe gefühl dass das hier nicht richtig drinne ist ich ziehe da ich
ziehe da jetzt einfach mal dran oder muss ich das drücken oder ziehen das ganze vergessen
da passiert gar nichts man merkt es ja auch wenn man den einschaltet will er sich drehen
da kann sich aber nicht drehen ich glaube ich muss das abschrauben oben ich glaube ich
muss den also ich vermute mal ich muss den Mist hier abschrauben was wird das dann fertig
ist wir flaschen den das ist eigentlich ist das hier in den motor unten dran kommt dieses
ding und damit kannst du dann ventile auf und zu machen das problem ist nur das funktioniert
noch nicht beim auslieferungszustand ist zu klein geht nicht vor irgendwelchen anderen
ich schraube das jetzt einfach mal ab wir gucken wir gucken jetzt mal ob das ob das vielleicht
wirklich nicht richtig dran ist und dann muss das wieder dran kriegen also der controller
funktioniert denke ich ich meine das licht geht an es sind 3,3 volt drauf kann man eigentlich
nix sagen alter das ding ich sage euch das ist echt das ist immer also jetzt kann es
angreifen aber vorher war das wirklich koste ei draufbacken und das sollte in so in ruhende
zustand definitiv nicht sein kann man das überhaupt so aufmachen ich hoffe mal das funktioniert
so geht das jetzt rund ah ja ok jetzt geht's ab muss das wirklich abmachen so chat merkt
euch mal du diese pose so muss ich wieder drauf machen hier so so muss ich wieder drauf
machen china chinesen zeug einer das kann nie funktionieren irgendwo in shang shang
sitzt jetzt einer da guckt meinen stream und lacht mich aus ich brauche glaube ich gleich
ein bisschen klopapier oder so weil das ist klebrig ah hier geht am hier geht der motor
dran ok wird sehr gerne raus kriegen so vielleicht komme ich jetzt dran das ist wirklich nicht
richtig drin ich sage es euch das irgendwas ist da nicht richtig wir machen jetzt den
motor raus und gucken ob der sich dreht wenn man es draußen hat und wenn er ab ist und
sich nicht dreht dann ist das ding im arsch wollen wir mal gucken wie ich den raus kriege
ist immer noch ein bisschen hot jetzt gucken wir mal ob der sich dreht jetzt bin ich jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt wir müssen hier aufpassen dass wir die kabel nicht abkriegen ok jetzt
mache ich an und wir gucken ob das ich meine jetzt kann er ja nicht mehr blockiert sein
also wenn er sich jetzt nicht dreht ist das ding gebrocken er dreht sich er dreht sich
kogas macht er wird der motor jetzt heiß es geht so ich meine er ist immer noch heiß
ich sollte ihn erstmal abkühlen lassen wir können ja mal gucken ich lasse ihn mal abkühlen
ich lasse ihn jetzt mal in ruhe wir können wir können mit dem esp weiter machen ich muss
nur ein bisschen aufpassen dass ich den kram hier oben jetzt nicht aus versehen abreiße
während ich da gerade zugange bin also das ding ist echt ganz schön ganz schön heiß
gerade wahrscheinlich ist das getriebe blockiert das heißt wenn ich jetzt ok ich drehe jetzt
mal hier sollte sich das nicht sollte sich das nicht eigentlich drehen wenn ich hier
unten guck mal wenn ich hier unten an dem stift drehe sollte sich das eigentlich sollte
ich noch mit dem stift hier unten entsperren können wenn der motor kaputt ist aber wenn
ich den stift hier unten drehe dann dreht sich nichts ach guck mal hier was denn das
ist dann doch irgendwie die entriegelung das problem ist nur wenn ich hier dran ach jetzt
kann ich das war blockiert leute das blockiert lull was ist das für ein crap das ist kaputt
das ist broken life dass das das blockt aus irgendwelchen gründen soll ich wie gesagt
ich lasse ihn jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter abkühlen dass ich dann gucken kann ob er
wirklich warm wird oder nicht wenn er sich wenn er kogas macht ich meine ein bisschen
warm werden ist ja ok vielleicht kriegen wir den wieder zugang so und der motor ist
dann hier drinnen da kommt dann hier rein das heißt wir können jetzt mal gucken ob
sich ja guck mal wunderbar also das funktioniert an sich vollkommen in ordnung gut merkt ihr
mal wie lange das dauert bis der bis er abkühlt ja was machen wir jetzt in der zeit bis der
motor abgekühlt kann aus dem fenster hängen da wird er schneller kühl schmiert das ding
mal da kannst du doch gar nicht schmieren guck mal das ist zu was willst du hier schmieren
das ding hier das hier ist das da das so das könnte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr haben
aber aber es ist schon bd 40 ist kein schmiermittel das funktioniert
nicht bd 40 ist eigentlich eher so zum sauber machen
ja wir müssen jetzt warten bis es abgekühlt ist
alter warum ist das china guckt mal ich habe das ding 1 zu 1 sowies ist bestellt
bei amazon warum ist das broken schon mal den chip ranlöten das problem ist den chip
muss hier oben ranlöten da gehen genau diese kabel vorbei ich habe angst dass ich irgendwas
abreiße wenn ich da nicht wenn ich da nicht richtig aufpasse wir könnten wir könnten
es mal probieren aber das ist halt auch pains champion gemacht alter
ne das funktioniert nicht richtig das funktioniert nicht richtig so vielleicht so vielleicht
ok doch wir löten schon wir löten das schon mal ich habe jetzt hier so viel scheiße rum
liegen ich habe gar keinen platz irgendwas zu löten so machen wir das erst mal weg das
kommt weg das kommt weg so hier alles alles in die eck so jetzt ist anders rum als vorher
das heißt wir schnappen uns jetzt mal ein kabel für wie sie sie wie sie sie nehmen wir
mal hier das das lila lila kabel im usb lötkolben ne ne ne ich mach sie mit meiner erza lötstation
mache ich schon mal an so und dann nehmen wir das haben wir hier noch grau für ground
und und das lila für wie sie sie gut das passt schon alles klar so jetzt müssen wir
das natürlich umgedreht machen weil wir haben sie andersrum jetzt das heißt das hier müsste
wie sie sie sein und das hier müsste ground sein also löten wir das mal dran schnappen
wir mal bis sie lösen ich hoffe ich habe hier genug platz das wird nämlich gerade ein
bisschen anspruchsvoll ist echt ist echt kein platz wow fuck meine güt ich habe alles über
das kabel drüber jetzt wird es lustig die lötkolben hier raus bekommen er ist natürlich
jetzt schön 300 grad heiß egal einfach dran ziehen easy so zack so so hau hau zu willst
du nicht erst mal das ding zusammen stellen und schauen ob sich der stellwerk ich kann
es nicht zusammen ich will erst mal gucken ob sich bewegt wenn es aus ist also wenn es
nirgendswo dran ist und dann sollte es sich bewegen aber nicht mega heiß werden das ist
immer noch warm hier wenn sich das bewegt und mega heiß wird dann ist der motor irgendwie
im arsch vermute ich zumindest mal so also auf geht's löten wir mal machen wir da mal
ein bisschen lösen dran um zu gucken ich habe mir ja so ein ich habe mir so ein so ein
so ein tritt hand ding gekauft da habe ich jetzt überhaupt keinen platz für wir machen
jetzt wir machen jetzt einfach hier ein bisschen lösen dran hallo habe ich nicht an ach ich
habe gar nicht eingeschaltet lull ich habe eingeschaltet ach ich habe mir den stecker
rausgemacht big brain time massive massive brain ja das läuft leider nicht so wie geplant
geplant hätte das alles wunderbar funktioniert hätte der der wer der d1 mini nicht kaputt
gegangen oder kaputt gewesen wer der motor hätte gleich funktioniert kriege ich das
hier irgendwie rein
das doch so jetzt ist aber an so 300 grad progers auf geht's wenn der motor im arsch
ist er jetzt eben nicht gedreht naja ich weiß ja nicht wie schnell dass ich normalerweise
drehen soll vielleicht ist er ja wirklich irgendwie geplockt oder irgendwas im arsch
und der dreht sich halt viel langsamer als er sein müsste so habe sie lösen an den
kabels dran und jetzt müssen wir mal schauen also wie sie sie der da das heißt der da
wie warm ist es aber der motor ist immer noch ein bisschen warm also das heißt von der
idee her schiebt es mal ein bisschen weiter runter das heißt hier oben man mal wie sie
sieht ran ich muss mal kurz gucken auf fack ich sehe nix sag ich muss mal davor setzen
ich muss mal davor setzen ich hoffe ihr seht ich hoffe ihr seht wenigstens was ich sehe
auch nichts so schauen wir mal also ich sehe ich sehe von hier echt nichts und ich kann
ich ran weil ich da mein key light habe alles mal please please schmelzhorn ok es ist nicht
richtig fest aber so ein bisschen also das müsste wie sie sie sein und das heißt das
hier müsste jetzt crown sein aber das mal irgendwie so müsste ich müsste da halt mal
näher dran ich habe keinen winkel wo ich näher dran kann
aber warum schmilzt das denn nicht ich mache da mal ein bisschen drauf ein bisschen dran
das schmilzt ja mal gar nichts seck das muss ich mir jetzt erstmal ein bisschen vorrücken
dass ich das ich was sehe ich sehe hier wirklich gar nichts das ist mega pains champ mit dem
key light rüber ich sehe nichts jetzt jetzt schmilzt ok ok pass
so mal das ding mal wieder aus also von der idee her einmal ground einmal ground dran einmal
wie sie sieht dran sollte sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren jetzt gucken wir erstmal ob
der motor tut da hat es drauf vielleicht vielleicht zumindest habe ich jetzt weg weg geätzt so
der motor ist lauwarm ich mache jetzt mal an wenn der jetzt heiß wird dann stimmt irgendwas
nicht der sollte vom einfachen drehen jetzt ja nicht wirklich wahnsinnig heiß werden kogas
gucken ich lege den jetzt hin dass man sieht dass der sich dreht so
da dreht sich seht ihr kogas rotation sieht man dass er sich dreht ja ne
ne der wird nicht heiß der wird nicht heiß das ist eigentlich alles ok
ne passt eigentlich eigentlich in ordnung ok dann bauen dann bauen wir es wieder mal
zusammen und hoffen dass es jetzt funktioniert sehr sehr sehr mehr wobei leute wisst ihr
was wir müssen es gar nicht zusammen bauen wir machen jetzt erstmal den esp dran und
gucken ob alles funktioniert weil warum soll ich den jetzt zusammen bauen wir gucken erstmal
ob alles funktioniert macht den esp dran oder esp sollte zumindest zumindest buten jetzt
ne also wir haben ja wenn das hier stimmt was wir gemalt haben dann haben wir ja vcc
dran also 3,3 volt und ground das heißt wenn ich das jetzt richtig einstöpsel also sprich
wir müssen jetzt einmal hier oben links und dann da unten auf g also der hier kommt auf
g und der da oh der ist nicht richtig fest das sehe ich gleich der ist im arsch der ist
richtig fest sagt alter ich hab es nicht gesehen eben vielleicht krieg ich vielleicht vielleicht
hält er ja fest genug dass ich mal buten kann 3,3 volt gucken wir mal ganz schön am
wackeln hat er gepackt jetzt jetzt geht er ab jetzt geht er ab jetzt wo ich einstöpsel
jetzt jetzt na super wird das die neue höllenmaschine ja eindeutig eindeutig ich sehe dass die scheiße
ist wenn man das mit dem keylight macht ich sehe nix ich kann auch meinen kopf da nicht
hin machen das ist mega scheiße das ist wirklich richtig richtig müll ich sehe nix kann nix
machen kannst du mal angehen jawoll gib gib alles an das ist einfach müll ich sehe gar
nix jetzt so machen dann sehe ich vielleicht ein bisschen was wenn ich mich davor setze
weil genau da wo ich meinen kopf hin mache ist das keylight glaube ich muss das ding
mal bisschen wärmer stellen das steht grad auf 300 grad vielleicht ist das irgendwas
was ich 244 jawoll gib ihm jetzt jetzt hält das auch muss man grad ein bisschen wärmer
machen ok esp ist dran schauen wir mal ob das jetzt wenigstens so funktioniert wie ich mir
das gedacht habe oder esp hat geplinkt habt ihr es gesehen plink stellt das heißt wenn
ich glück habe da ist er ok stromversorgung vom esp funktioniert schon mal wieder access
point ist der beste cute cute ap gut der ist erreichbar also esp funktioniert sehr schön
also prinzipiell von der idee her klappt das jetzt muss natürlich mal gucken wie die anderen
pins sind welche pins brauchen wir da jetzt für wisst ihr was mich wisst ihr was mich
sehr sehr wundert dass der motor dauerhaft dreht wenn das ding booted da ist doch irgendwas
procken oder normalerweise soll der noch ausgehen nach nach der weile
wir können ja wir können ja noch mal die gp aus für den motor dran löten und gucken
ob das irgendwas bringt die frage ist nur welcher gp ist das selbst zum endpoint finden
ja das könnte sein
das wird es wahrscheinlich sein ja so also wir haben ja hier dieses komische bild also
es ist gpio also es ist ja hier im prinzip nur auf der seite das heißt so rum es ist
quasi machts noch mal groß es ist ja auf der seite nichts dran außer ground das einzige
was noch dran ist das tx rx oder sowas das ist egal guckt hier weiß ich ob man das jetzt
richtig sieht also hier ist nix dran außer ground das heißt die gp aus müssen irgendwo
hier drüben sein angeschlossen ist oben das ist wie sie sie pwm 0 und pwm 4 also das
heißt eigentlich müssen wir hier noch zwei kabel dran löten und die dann irgendwie mal
auf unseren esp mappen und gucken was passiert schauen wir mal wir gucken uns wir gucken
uns vielleicht mal die schon bestehenden templates an also alle geräte walwe wo ist da gaben
da hier moos möß möß gas waterwalf alles klar die mößwalf die wollen wir uns jetzt
angucken so was ist gemerkt gpio 12 ist button gpio 13 ist relay ich würde sagen ich baue
das jetzt einfach mal so nach weil das ist das ding müsste gehen wir von ausbau gleich
sein also gpio 13 der alte controller wird da schon über gpio senden sendest du nicht
doppelt naja ich kann den gpio wieder ausschalten ja mal gucken was passiert ich hab keine ahnung
wir schauen einfach mal also gpio 13 ist relay und gpio 12 ist button 1 so wo ist wo ist die
1 mini pinout wo ist gpio 12 und wo ist gpio 13 gpio 13 ist eins neben 3,3 volt und der
nächste eins weiter ok easy und wo ist es hier jetzt vergleichbar mit dem anderen 13
ah direkt ok direkt neben neben 3,3 volt die zwei pins muss ich das ergibt sinn das ergibt
sinn das ist genau die die kontakt haben guckt das sind genau die pins hier neben die angeschlossen
sind ich soll den alten controller weg machen ok leute frage an den chat soll ich den alten
controller ab abföhnen jetzt schon ohne zu ohne mit dem esp vorher zu testen soll ich
den alten controller ab machen ja mach ab weg damit ok chat dann hab ich dann hab wenigstens
nicht ich das geprickt sondern der chat hat geprickt da kann ich kann ich viel besser
mit leben muss nur gucken dass ich nix anderes hier aus versehen ablöte ich muss mal kurz
das heißluftstells ding holen so excellent
leute wir hatten ihn lange nicht mehr da aber der heiz champ ist wieder zurück ich brauche
eine freie steckdose und ich brauche vor allem ein bisschen platz weil hier ist wirklich
gerade absolut durcheinander gut das werde ich gleich abdenken drauf pußte pußtstells
machen zange jetzt brauchen wir ein bisschen also wenn man so sachen mit der halt mit dem
heißluft ich würde nicht fest dran ziehen wenn man fest dran zieht dann ist das problem
dass man die pets abreißt wenn man die pets abreißt dann ist kacke nee wir machen keine
vorhersagen ich mache es jetzt einfach also mal löt netzteil raus heißluft rein jetzt
dann ist ja wenn die pets ab sind ist rib dann ist wirklich rib so man muss jetzt ein
bisschen aufpassen dass man nicht aus versehen ich mache erst mal die kabel ab man muss auf
dass man nicht aus versehen irgendwie dass man nicht irgendwie andere sachen abmacht
ok so jetzt haben wir den kram ab und jetzt muss ich irgendwie schauen dass ich das hin
bekomme da oben dran ziehen leicht so dass es abgeht ja ja ggs ich hoffe es ist ab ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob es ab ist vielleicht gehen die kabel ab nee nee nee deswegen da
muss man echt aufpassen da muss man echt aufpassen ich glaube es ist es ist ab ja ich glaube
ich muss hier noch mal ein bisschen warm machen aber prinzipial ist es ab und die pets sind
noch dran oder nicht bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher werden wir gleich sehen wenn
die pets wenn die pets ab sind ist monka es dann ist dann ist vorbei wenn die pets ab
sind ist vorbei ich mache das erst mal kurz raus dass mit einer hand ich halt mal rauskrieg
die pets erkennt man nicht richtig also wenn die pets ab sind ist echt ripp wobei ich meine
schonender kann ich den scheiß nicht ab machen ich glaube die pets sind ab die pets wie warum
sind die pets wie wie wie ich habe nicht dran gezogen ich habe es einfach nur warm gemacht
was ist das für eine china kacke wieder guck mal ich glaube ich glaube die pets sind wirklich
ab warum wie kann das sein oder oder doch nicht ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wir probieren
es ich mache mal die lüt kohl mann ich guck mal ob ich da ein bisschen lötchen drauf
krieg vielleicht habe ich ja glück und es tut noch
schauen wir mal ah die pets sind noch dran alles gut die pets sind noch dran excellent
alles gut easy kann weitergehen leute kann weitergehen sah nur so aus als wären sie ab
sind nicht ab ok wo ist mein zettel hier also ground vcc und dann die drei kabels dran also
auf gehts zack zack ich meine ich könnte auch mal wobei ich habe ich habe den d1 mini
mit pins drauf dann muss ich sowas mit so einem kabel mann also ok das müssen wir jetzt
irgendwie so hinkriegen dass wir das danach auch wieder warte mal ja doch alter das ist
mega hängen geblieben ok ground ist dran ihr erkennt das glaube ich nicht richtig gut
oder das problem ist wenn ich das so drehe dass ihr es gut erkennt erkenne ich heute
nix das ist halt mega klein ich mach das jetzt auch so weil ich muss es ja irgendwie
ins gehäuse bekommen später gut ok das hat ordentliche connection das ist ziemlich fest
jetzt so ok und jetzt noch zwei gpi aus ich glaube mehr brauchen wir nicht wir haben ja
gesagt gpio 12 gpio 12 und gpio 13 brauma also da nehmen wir mal hier also das blaue
das den scheiß das ding kann weg das blau für gpio 13 das blau für gpio 13 und das
haben wir noch grünes grünes grüne nehmen wir für gpio 12 ok gut also ich muss nur gucken
dass der kram sich nicht berührt das müssen wir anders machen muss ich irgendwie so hier
muss man echt aufpassen mit dem ding ich glaube jetzt könnt ihr auch ein bisschen was erkennen
halbwegs hoffe ich mal so aber ich nicht null perfekt jetzt kann ich wieder nichts sehen
da kriege ich das gehäuse zu glaube gerade so gerade so viel ich glaube da kriege ich
das gehäuse kriege ich zu mit jawoll passt sehr gut hält sitzt passt wackelt und an luft
hätte man aber jetzt gesagt gut so jetzt haben wir die gpi aus dran jetzt haben wir
ground dran wie sie sieht ran jetzt können wir mal den esp anschließen gucken was passiert
das war jetzt bevor ich den motor anschließen den motor muss aber hinlegen dass man ihn
mal ein bisschen sieht so sieht man den motor ja da sieht man hier ob es gleich kogas macht
oder nicht also dann schließen wir mal an 3,3 volt da drauf dann haben wir ground zum
glück habe ich mal sinnvolle farben genommen ground haben wir da drauf so dann haben wir
gpio 13 habe ich gesagt 1 weiter als 3,3 volt und dann gpio 12 noch eins weiter jetzt bin
ich ja mal gespannt ob ich das richtig angeschlossen habe nein wir machen jetzt keine prediction
wir machen jetzt einfach weiter so ohne template in tas motor wird es eh nicht funktionieren
so das ist eh schon mal sicher so netzteil mal gucken was passiert wenn ich jetzt anschließe
erstmal kurz gucken also ich habe ground auf ground das ist das ist wichtig also wenn
ich das jetzt verkackt aber ich mein die one mini kaputt hat es geplinkt leute der motor
dreht sich warum dreht sich der motor standardmäßig das ist komplett wir aber er wird nicht warm
ok also wir haben das ding an wir haben das es antwortet auch ok das motor ok und jetzt
müssen wir was einstellen jetzt müssen wir was einstellen also configuration module ne
template ist es glaube ich ne template so also demöse demöse gas water valve nehmen
wir jetzt einfach mal also gpio button gpio 12 ist button eins und gpio 13 ist relay eins
wo ist es relay relay eins name ist gaben so safe main menu
der motor dreht sich jetzt mache ich on und das nichts passiert mache ich off und das
nichts passiert null na geil das das hat so schon mal nicht funktioniert habe ich das
richtig angeschlossen aber der motor wird nicht warm das schon mal gut habe ich das
jetzt richtig restart der sollte eigentlich automatisch restarten stimmt der hat noch
nicht restarted sonst würde hier was anderes dastehen korrekt ne das ist richtig das hat
nicht hat nicht das stimmt auch nicht da müsste jetzt da müsste jetzt da müsste jetzt ding
stehen gaben das habe ich falsch gemacht template ach hier activate gaben alles klar
das kann licht angegangen guck mal on off licht ohne dass der motor on off geht vielleicht
ist es vertauscht seht ihr das das geht es licht an das ist das lit das ist die led von
vorne vielleicht ist es vertauscht vielleicht ist es vertauscht seck seht ihr das guck led
ist hier unten an vielleicht sind die gpios vertauscht ok der motor wird schon warm wenn
der permanent läuft aber diese motoren sind ja auch nicht für permanent laufen gedacht
ok wir haben wir haben mit dem mit dem button vielleicht geht es jetzt einfach auch vielleicht
geht es jetzt auch einfach und ich muss den motor einfach nur wieder einbauen ich werde
ich vertauscht das noch mal weil von der idee her ist ja eigentlich richtig wenn ich das
relay schalte moment moment ich kann auch testen ob es richtig ist ich drücke einfach
den knopf oben wenn ich den knopf oben drücke und es geht im webinterface auf on dann ist
es richtig rum naja on so achtung knopf bäm leuchtet und es geht auf on ist richtig angeschlossen
richtig angeschlossen den motor den hältst du nicht so einfach fest so sehr gut dann
baue ich den scheiß mal wieder ein und dann hoffen wir dass es funktioniert ja ich habe
den strom rausgezogen deswegen dreht er sich nicht mehr die ganze zeit hat er sich weiter
durch weiter weiter gedreht ja jetzt ist der motor wieder relativ warm ist das normal dass
so ein motor warm wird nachdem der eine minute maßig gedreht hat die dinger sind ja nicht
dafür gedacht eine minute an zu sein die sind ja meistens nur fünf sekunden an und dann
wieder aus oder ich habe keine erfahrung mit mit motoren na gut dann bauen wir das
dann bauen wir das teil mal wieder zusammen und gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert also nur
mal kurz gucken dass ich nichts kaputt mache langsam vorsichtig ja und jetzt na fuck das
ist das dumme wenn es so gut geschmiert ist dann rutscht vielleicht sollte ich das vorher
reinsetzen oder oder andersrum dann machen wie macht man das jetzt am besten so ok hier
oben ist un uncomfortable zu halten weil hot es fuck die kriegen das jetzt rein am besten
erst mal warten bis es abgekühlt ist deswegen wird es auch nicht schlimm sein wenn es so
heiß ist nein zumindest muss das ding dann hier später rein ok ich meine viel also großartig
falsch zusammen bauen kann man das nicht das muss dahin das muss dahin aber wozu dieses
ding hier unten ist habe ich immer noch nicht gecheckt guck vorher ob sich das noch freitritt
du meinst mit dem ding da dran gesteckt kann ich machen aber das sollte sich doch eigentlich
nichts tun ja kogas es kogart noch achtung war das kabel ab ja teste noch mal also hier
ja was auch immer mit diesem stift ist keine ahnung aber hier dass das funktioniert das
dreht sich die große preisfrage ist muss es am anfang offen oder zu sein ist wahrscheinlich
egal deswegen guckt er wahrscheinlich am anfang nach machen wir es mal halb machen wir es
mal halb also so halbe halbe was dann passiert ok der sollte es am anfang ja checken wo stopp
ist ok kann man den wieder angreifen naja wie geht das jetzt what the hell ok ich glaube
ich habs da bevor ich den jetzt festschraube gucken wir mal ob sich das noch ordentlich
dreht kogas kogas time der dreht sich noch der dreht sich funst ok das war jetzt weil
er nicht richtig fest war jetzt ist er wieder raus aber ok ok nice nice also prinz prinzipiell
gehts so jetzt muss ich das mal wieder richtig drauf machen ich hab ein problem der hängt
es denn jetzt was ist das was ist da abgefallen omg es rieseln teile raus was ist da abgefallen
omg es rieseln teile raus
he ich hab das doch eben schon mal drauf gekriegt warum krieg ich das jetzt einmal drauf
jetzt blick ich schnell mal durch ich habs doch eben schon mal drauf gekriegt also ich
muss den zurück drehen dreht sich nix wird schon nicht so wichtig sein ja wahrscheinlich
ach guck mal jetzt jetzt dreht sich nicht mehr aha aha guck mal jetzt dreht sich jetzt
dreht sich nicht mehr but why das ist raus jetzt dreht sichs wieder alter was ist das
für ein shit das ist locker unten das rutscht dann einfach raus alter china chinesen kram
ok wieder rein gucken dass wir es irgendwie hinbekommen hallo sag mal man kriegt man kriegt
man kann das doch nur in eine richtung rein machen ah jetzt kogas kogas time ok jetzt
ist drauf jetzt schraube ich mal fest oder gucken wir mal hoffentlich gehts jetzt
machen das jetzt am besten rein oh die kirby playlist ist vorbei das geht nicht die muss
restartet werden ok exzellent hätte ich mal einen gescheiten schraubendreher stelle es
hier am start dann so wahrscheinlich muss man das noch ein bisschen einrücken dass das
so passt ok gut also schrauben wir mal so ein ding hier rein hören wir mal dass ihr
wieder gescheit reinkriegt ich hoffe so na auf so ok schraubend andere kram soll ich
noch mal anmachen kurz und gucken ob noch sich alles dreht ja dreht sich noch alles
ich mach wieder raus ich hab's gesehen es hat sich gedreht hat es hat es hat kogas
gemacht so nein das ist natürlich dumm weil der motor auch magnetisches so ich schraube
den kram jetzt fest und dann gucken wir mal ich bin echt gespannt ob das jetzt funktioniert
mit dem controller ich mein wir haben den chip abgelötet wir können ihn nicht mehr
an anderweitig in ja retten also wenn jetzt ich mein hier das ist der original chip wenn
das ding jetzt nicht geht ist halt rip dann ist es vorbei das also ich werde das ding
garantiert nicht wieder dran blöden und außerdem ich will ihn ja sogar nicht verwenden
ich könnte natürlich auch mal einen richtigen schraubenzieher holen dafür dann würde das
auch ordentlich funktionieren aber wozu
so drei schrauben müssen zum testen jetzt erst mal reichen der wird ja nicht einfach
rausspringen mit drei schrauben was auch immer das hier für ein teil war ich habe
keine ahnung ich hoffe man braucht es nicht es ist mir einfach entgegen gefallen ok machen
wir mal an und gucken mal also es dreht sich auf jeden fall ja es dreht sich
und jetzt ist er glaube ich am ende angekommen jetzt mache ich mal on was dann passiert
hallo ah ich muss refreshen ok was can't be reached
was ist jetzt ist jetzt irgendwas broken kabel abgerissen
ne da ist alles fest mal gucken ob die led blinkt wenn ich einschalte die led blinkt nicht
mehr ok aber warum wir haben noch gar nichts gemacht also sie haben jetzt gar nichts geändert
jetzt sind die pets ab quatsch ist nichts ab ist alles noch ist alles noch wunderbar
dran und gut
ja aber sag mal wenn der motor blockiert dann sollte doch der controller angehen
was denn jetzt ok
ja ich glaube der motor ist wieder raus gerutscht
da war so wenn der motor rausrutscht das ein aber der controller sollte doch noch angehen
das ding ist im arsch guckt mal das rutscht immer hier unten raus obwohl es das nicht
darf warum macht es denn sowas anzeige ist gestellt aber der controller sollte ja zumindest
angehen jetzt ist er angegangen jetzt ist er angegangen
ich habe sie im blinken sehen was ist das was ist das wieder für zeug
nein das hat damit nichts zu tun topf verteilen hat damit nichts zu tun das ist irgendwo von
unten irgendwas anderes jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch ok gut gut dass wir ich muss da
mal kurz wieder raus machen was ist das für eine kacke was ist das was ist das für eine
china kacke wieder macht das ding jetzt noch mal raus wir gucken auch gleich mal wo da unten
irgendein teil abgefallen ist gut dass ich nur drei dran gemacht habe jetzt geht schneller
ich muss euch noch voll voll voll screen machen hat ihr das all das von amazon das von amazon
so warum ist das im arsch immer wieder raus machen das muss man auch total eklig kippen
dass man das rauskriegt ok coga cogas time gleich gucken ob es jetzt ob es jetzt angeht
wenn es so ist das das blockt guck mal das rutscht das rutscht raus das ist mega mega
hängen gebliebenes china kram zeug was ist denn das wer hat sie wer hat sie das da wieder
rausgedacht oh wisst ihr wo das teil abgefallen ist das war nie richtig dran ich glaube jetzt
habe ichs gecheckt guckt mal das war die ganze zeit das ist glaube ich der stopp guckt mal
hier unten da sind so ich weiß ich ob ihr das erkennt hier sind so zwei ne guckt mal
hier sind so zwei rote schalter drin sieht man das hier hinten sind so zwei rote schalter
der einer hat einen schalter dran der andere nicht und das ist der stopp vom motor und der
stopp schalter ist ab bei dem einen was natürlich ziemlich sagt genau zwei switches bei dem
anderen ist eine dran hier nicht das kriege ich da aber wahrscheinlich nicht wieder dran
denke ich mal oder oder zumindest müsste ich dann den kram hier unten ausbauen das
kriegt man alles kriegt ok das kriegt man raus ok jetzt jetzt jetzt hier jetzt guckt
mal da einer hat einen schalter der andere nicht da kann ich ja mal von hunter drauf
drücken dass jetzt gestoppt ist ok wir gucken mal ob der controller überhaupt noch angeht
vielleicht sollte ich den nicht auf den schraubenschluss legen das nicht so mag er nicht so er hat
geplinkt der motor dreht sich und er ist auch wieder verfügbar
was passiert jetzt wenn ich den switch von hand drücke so als wäre der motor gestoppt
ah dann hört er auf exzellent das war die das war von anfang an kaputt leute ich sag
euch das war von anfang an kaputt das war nicht richtig dran 100 pro die sache ist bloß
die wie um alles in der welt soll ich den kack da wieder dran bekommen guckt euch mal
an wie klein seht ihr das guckt mal wie klein aber ich muss mich groß machen wie klein das
ist das kannst du doch komplett guckt mal hier kannst doch komplett vergessen wie solche
wie solche das da wieder reinkriegen vor allem wo da irgendwo da hinten bisschen große
zange ich weiß aber ich habe nichts anderes gerade das müsste also von der idee her müsste
das da rein aber das kannst du das kannst du komplett vergessen alter das kannst du
mal komplett knicken dass das da wieder reinzukriegen müsste sich mit unhoffentlich die motorrichtung
erinnern ich gehe mal davon aus dass das nur funktioniert wenn er vorher einmal geschaltet
hat weil er dann einmal durchgefahren ist pinzette nee das ist guck mal das ist das
ist brutalst dünn so verpasst hast bei dem china ding war von anfang an ein teil abgebrochen
und deswegen geht es nicht ich gucke jetzt ob ich das irgendwie irgendwie da wieder
rein krieg wenn ich war es hat zumindest ich weiß schon mal wie rum aber im finger kommst
du da halt nicht hin ich komme da nicht mit dem finger rein bräuchte längere finger
das ist doch scheiße das ist doch scheiße alter was ein billig scheiß aber ich krieg
das ja mal raus hier finger nein ich meine ich weiß wie sie rein muss aber das muss
man da reindrücken 100 pro das muss man irgendwie reindrücken wie aber wie auch immer und das
es trägt auf jeden fall nichts dazu bei dass ich nichts gescheit sehe
ich glaube das kriegen wir das kriegen wir nicht gefixt wenn man da ja wenigstens mit
dem finger hinkommen würde gescheit nicht funktioniert alles im weg ist dann könnte
man es vielleicht irgendwie probieren
ich glaube das ist auch unten kaputt dass das geht da gar nicht richtig rein das geht
da gar nicht richtig rein ich meine ich habe es jetzt drin das geht gleich wieder raus
ich glaube ich glaube das bringt gar nichts wenn ich das da wieder reinkrieg hier auf
der seite ist es ist es stabil drinnen aber wahrscheinlich ist es hier abgebrochen oder
so ja feels bad man siehst du mal an so einem kleinen scheiß den kannst kannst jetzt scheitern
am ende ich meine wir könnten hier auch irgendwas davor legen der muss ja hier nur erkennen
dass er gestoppt ist wir könnten auch ich habe eine idee wir kleben wir kleben da einfach
irgendwas dazwischen oder oder wir legen da doch doch doch wir kleben da einfach was
dazwischen weil im prinzip muss er ja erkennen quasi wenn er stoppt blockiert er hier und
wenn er stoppt soll er soll er hier blockieren mit dem unterschied dass der hier das auf
der seite nicht also hier hinten nicht checkt wenn er in der posi ist wir könnten da was
eigentlich dazwischen kleben ja weil rein kriege ich das ding hier nicht mehr dass es
jetzt quasi das erkennt das müsste eigentlich klappen müsste eigentlich klappen da brauche
ich irgendwas dünnes was ich da was ich da hinten also hier guck mal irgendwas dünnes
was ich hier so an diesem vor diesen backen vor diesen backen hier legen kann vor diesen
roten roten backen das könnte man da nehmen kleb was auf zahnart ja sowas in der richtung
habe ich mir auch gedacht muss halt ein bisschen was festeres sein klebeband hätte ich aber
sind passendes dafür aber mal schon da jetzt nobel ans zahnart ja genau im endeffekt schon
büroklammer ne ne ne ne ne ist alles viel zu groß ich brauche was kleines ich guck
gerade mal ein micro sd kater stück pappe oder so vielleicht muss ja nicht viel sein
sowas hier das ist schon viel zu viel löten was soll es daran löten okay ganz nix gescheit
dran löten sowas hier keine ahnung das funktioniert doch im leben nicht so scheiße das funktioniert
doch so nicht aber da muss ja den stopp vom moto erkennen das war von anfang an das problem
das war von anfang das problem das war nie richtig dran deswegen hat er immer versucht
weiter zu drehen und war dann irgendwann blockiert das ist es leute das ist es ich achte euch
deswegen war das ding im arsch ich habe keine ahnung was da drauf kleben soll man im endeffekt
hier hinten hier drauf müsste das so ein bisschen so ein bisschen bobble deckel oder
so kein aber das doch auch mist ein heißkleber bobble vielleicht gar keine so schlechte idee
kann man mal probieren also muss halt halbwegs gleichmäßig sein oder ich mache einfach ich
mache einfach ein bisschen klebeband drauf und reißt das außen nicht ab müsste auch
gehen
gucken ob das passen würde ich mache das mit dem heißkleber chat das ist eine gute
idea wir machen einfach ein heißkleber hier hinten ein bisschen drauf fertig das müsste
schon reichen eigentlich soweit von der theorie guck mal mal ja was schlage ich dir denn vor
was soll man denn bitteschön machen wenn das ding abgeholt was willst du machen hat
ihr mal eine glorreiche idee außer zu sagen dass das alles schlecht ist so als erst mal
kurz gucken dass das angeht warten wir mal kurz ab
rein bochen und schrauben rein ja ja ja big brand idee wir bochen wir bochen hier mal
kurz in das metall kein ding so das heißt an die seite hier ja hierhin müssen wir mal
gucken ob das funkt da muss ich aber vorsichtig sein da muss ich echt da muss ich echt vorsichtig
sein dass da nicht zu viel drauf kommt schauen wir mal
besser besser ein bisschen weiter hinten dass das auch auf weil hinten ist ja da hinten
ist ja der switch also hier so da so hier hinten ist auf der eck oh geht noch nicht
mit halb teil ach ich glaube das ist eigentlich genug wenn da heißkleber dran ist
der motor wird er dann nicht mehr heiß weil es blockt da kann es mal warm werden jetzt
die musik jetzt darf ich jetzt jetzt exquisite gut das müsste das müsste eigentlich schon
reichen leute muss gerade noch mal die die reste die reste entfernen
muss ja oben abschneiden das müsste eigentlich funktionieren
schritt ist schuld ah das funkt nicht gescheit
ok ok also wenn wir glück haben wenn wir glück haben funkt das ist scheiße das klappt
nicht das fällt das fällt auch gleich ab guckt mal hier so jetzt ist dran drin oder auch nicht
das funktioniert es geht ab ach was eine kacke man das das funktioniert so nicht das funktioniert
ich glaube das ist broken also rein kriege ich diesen komischen switch hier auf jeden
fall nicht mehr der ist ja komplett hinüber naja mit heißkleber kannst du knicken oh fuck
das kannst du vergessen das funkt nicht das hält da nicht richtig dran ok was könnte
man sonst noch machen wo habe ich denn dieses teil jetzt überhaupt hin da es ist bestimmt
abgebrochen der bügel ich glaube nicht dass den bügel reparieren kannst das ist so ein
3 send switch da kann es nichts reparieren das bestimmt abgebrochen jetzt für immer
das das fällt immer raus das ist im arsch das kaputt auch schon bescheuerte konstruktion
irgendwie ich glaube das ist ja eigentlich drinne festgelötet so ja ja das ist bestimmt
normalerweise hier drinne festgelötet aber kannst du voll vergessen den bügel als zahnrad
kleben das funktioniert nicht mal versuchen die platine weg zu machen wie kriegt man die
mal kurz gucken dass ich den kram weg kriege oh nee da komme ich nicht gescheit hin das
sind unten irgendwelche vergesst das kriege ich nicht gescheit das da bist jetzt noch
kleine ne ne ne da komme ich nicht gescheit hin ne das ist im arsch ich glaube das war
von anfang kaputt ich glaube nicht dass ich es irgendwie durch ausbauen kaputt gemacht
habe das würde sich auch genau mit dem problem decken dass der motor nicht check dass das
blockiert ist tja wie könnte man das fixen zurückschicken ja genau jetzt so so am besten
direkt zurückschicken wir brauchen irgendwas was den kram klickt hier hinten kannst du
nichts gescheit draufkleben da hält nix schickt das doch nicht zurück lull keck wait aller
ich brauche da irgendwas da muss irgendwas da muss irgendwas drauf dass es das hält
im zweifelsfall irgendwas dann auch nicht verrutscht das gar nicht so einfach da fällt
mir ja nicht so nix gescheit seins für weil ich meine es funktioniert der esp funktioniert
es funktioniert alles der stopp vom vom vom motor ist halt einfach kaputt was halt mal
extremster pains champ ist und ich komme da hinten nicht gescheit dran und rein kriegst
es ja auch nicht gescheit so müsste das da eigentlich rein das problem ist nur dass
es halt nicht fest ist jetzt und ich sehe es auch beim anderen switch guckt das metal
halt hier oben raus und hier ist es das ist wahrscheinlich abgebrochen oder so ja da
machst du nix du kannst die platine nicht gescheit abschrauben du hast hier hinten hast
ein paar schrauben da kommst aber mit nichts wirklich gescheit dran höchstens so schräg
was was echt was noch beschissener ist sind es überhaupt für schrauben dahinten eine
kreuz aber selbst wenn ich die platine abschrauben was soll ich machen das ding krieg ich da
nicht krieg ich da nicht wieder dran ich habe echt keine ahnung mehr so langsam wie krieg
wie bring ich dem ding bei dass das den stopp erkennt so schon mal nicht da muss irgendwas
dazwischen gar nichts großartiges aus muss halt fest dahinten halten und da gibt es nix
kleben kann ich da nichts gescheites dran hier erkennt man mal lass mich mal hören
ob es hier stoppt ja easy hier stoppt direkt kannst du das nicht oft beseitigt machen
ne kannst du nur ein relay schalten und gut ist das muss das erkennt er alles selbst
ich schneide da garantiert kein gebinde rein ja da fällt mir nichts ein könnte man machen
also mir fällt wirklich gar nichts ein was irgendwie praktikabel wäre ich weiß ich kann
wirklich den kleber man nehmen oder drauf pappen vielleicht bringt es irgendwas man mehr
als probieren ich brauche eine schere macht jetzt einfach ein stück kleber drauf man was
willst du machen macht jetzt einfach ein stück kleber drauf so massiv massiv kleber mal
gucken ob das jetzt schaltet keine ahnung mal gucken ich muss mal hören das ist halt
auch zu weich klebt er jetzt den bügel drauf nee ich kann da nichts drauf kleben wenn ich
jetzt was draufklebe dann klebt das ja und hängt dahinten fest wenn es da dran kommt
ne das klappt nicht
ich habe wirklich keinen plan jetzt der bügel der funktioniert ja auch nicht einfach nur
durch vorhanden sein sondern er funktioniert weil der bügel so schräg ist und wenn es
hier drückt drückt das hinten dagegen das geht ja nur weil das so schräg ist auch irgendwas
was halbwegs fest ist dass das auch kein metallkontakt das egal ich brauche irgendwas aus den schalter
drückt aber es geht auch es geht auch schon wieder ab hier guck das kannst du das kannst
du alles vergessen das ist scheiße das klappt das ist im arsch das ist ripp das hinüber
ich sehe jetzt nichts praktikables was man da machen könnte obwohl das ist halt echt
bitter weil es funktioniert alles es ist alles komplett also das wird jetzt gehen der
controller geht alles geht ich ersetz den mikro switch nicht das ist auch nicht praktikabel
jetzt da müsste ich erstmal einen bestellen so ein habe ich bestimmt nicht da also mir
fällt da wirklich nichts ein was man jetzt machen könnte lieber an den schalter ja klar
und dann schalt der schalter gar nicht mehr da bohrst du nicht so einfach rein guck mal
das ist massiver block metall ne heißkleber habe ich probiert heißkleber bleibt den nicht
richtig dran hängen wir haben alles schon mehr oder weniger durch mir fällt wirklich
nichts mehr gescheites ein jetzt ich nichts mehr gescheites ein ich meine ja das problem
ist auch das ist das ist verbogen der kram guck mal da ist normalerweise ist er hier gar
nicht zusammen normalerweise ist das ich sehe das nämlich gerade auf der anderen seite normalerweise
ist er viel weiter auseinander deswegen ist er auch rausgefallen china kram alter
ganz ganz ganz vergessen also fällt jetzt wirklich nichts mehr ein was doofes der rest
funktioniert ja erst rein da machst du nix ich kann auch irgendwas gibt was man machen
könnte ja wenn es wenn es ja irgendwie so ein so ein heißkleber ding da hinten hängen
bleiben würde in der eck aber da klebste den schalter fest
ich habe versucht reinzustecken also da also ich sehe ich sehe auf der seite dass hier
das silberne raus guckt und selbst wenn ich das hier reindrücke wird da nix zumal man da
überhaupt nicht hinkommt du einfach nicht dran und ich kann das jetzt nicht gescheit
abmachen du hast gerade auf der instagram bestellt anzeige für ja ich mein weißt was scheiß
drauf ich kann es ja mal probieren kann aber versuchen die platine rauszuschrauben braucht
man dafür wird der da vielleicht oder dass ich da jetzt rum
hier gucken wir mal was ganz ganz kleines hier das mini small smallest das hier
ok das funst erstaunlich kommst da kommst du nicht hin ich mach das garantiert kaputt
macht das garantiert kaputt beim abschrauben ich mein mehr als kaputt kannst ja nicht
der kommst du nur mal dran wie sie kriege ich das jemals wieder rein und ich meine
das ist der kleinste kreuz den wir haben oder ist hier noch einer hier ist noch einer ob
der ist glaubt er ist besser ja der ist ganz gut
so und nun das krieg ich im leben immer dran
so und jetzt gucken wir mal ob das jetzt gucken wir mal ob wir da irgendwie dran
kommen ich glaube aber dass es verbogen ist und nicht recht funktioniert jetzt könnte
man theoretisch ne guck das fällt wieder raus
ne das ist das ist ab das das geht nicht rein das kann ich zwar reindrücken aber das hält
das hält nicht mehr drin also ich mach das rein und jetzt ist es eigentlich drin so wie
es sein soll aber wenn du drauf drückst geht es dir gleich wieder weg das ist ab
ich könnte noch mal irgendwie das rein machen und genau wir müssten das jetzt irgendwie
auseinander machen wieder null na das wird was soll man das auseinander kriegen alter
ihr seht ja guck mal das ist auf der anderen seite ist es viel mehr offen
das müsste man jetzt irgendwie auseinander kriegen
alter wie soll das funktionieren gescheit aufbiegen ja bieg das mal in der größe auf
ne festlöten klappt nicht das ist alles plastik drum rum
ich hab keine ahnung wie ich das mit genug kraft aufbiegen soll das das hält
schraube drehen dazwischen
ne keine chance bleibt überhaupt nicht drin
ja prinzipiell funktioniert das man hört es ja aber es ist halt einfach nicht fest
ne das hüpft immer wieder aus gerade unten springt es wieder raus
dann fahren mit dem stuhl
also es fällt schon mal nicht gleich wieder raus
doch das ist ribb
das ist auch total ausgeleiert da innen drin ich sehe das schon
dass man das könnte schon funktionieren
aber ich weiß nicht wie ich das gescheit auseinander kriegen soll
vor allem dass das dann drin bleibt also
das das hängt ja wirklich am seiden fahren das teil
ja wie kriegt man das jetzt wie kriegen wir das jetzt gescheit
auch ne idee ich hab also eine idee hätte ich noch
das jetzt ne ach ist das doch was ist das für ein arsch
alter vergiss es ne wenn ich ein kleber drauf mach dann klebe ich den schalter ja fest
kann das sein dass da normalerweise in der mitte was dazwischen ist
weg ist
jetzt ist dann das auseinander drückt
und da irgendwas gescheit auseinander biegen kann halte ich mal für ein gerücht
aber was ist das überhaupt für ne beschissene konstruktion
also welcher chineser hat sich das wieder ausgedacht
das war bestimmt ein chineser
ich mein das hält schon ja guckt aber das problem ist das das das das das
das fällt jetzt nach zweimal auf und zu machen wieder ab
das fällt noch ab bevor ichs wieder reinschraube sag ich euch
wo ist überhaupt der reinschrauber hier
wo haben wir hier den deutschletz ich kann mir ne ne mikroswitch bestellen
ja das war garantiert ein chineser der das hier zusammengebaut hat
100.000% ich war bestimmt kein brasilianer in shenzhen
was schlimm ist ich kann das gar nicht richtig reindrehen
das fällt gleich wieder raus leute
ich setz das jetzt mal zusammen und mal gucken was passiert
das fällt ab jaja da bin ich mir auch ziemlich sicher das das fällt garantiert ab
so das muss weg ja das würde das würde theoretisch halt schon funktionieren
aber das ich also ich gehe auch davon aus dass es abfällt
das mal dran setzen das drauf das fällt wieder ab
muss man hier einfädeln das funktioniert das nicht
das muss an dieser ein stelle eingefädelt werden
jetzt so ok jetzt ist es eingefädelt
ähm warte mal was muss ich jetzt noch machen ich schraub es jetzt unten mal fest
ich mach jetzt einfach mal hier zwei schrauben rein in der mitte
vielleicht damit jetzt ich mach jetzt einfach mal zwei schrauben
dass es nicht wieder runterfällt so da machen wir jetzt eine rein
ja da muss ich jetzt was anderes drauf machen komm ich nehm einfach den hier
so bevor ich einschalte schraube ich unten mal was drauf
dass es nicht dass es auch gar nicht auf die idee kommt irgendwie hoch zu
hoch zu gehen so mal kurz den kram hier weg machen
dann kann er da unten dann kann er da unten oh ne
das bewegt sich komplett frei das ding lull es dreht frei sozusagen
dann drehen wir mal da unten was drauf und gucken ob das dann aufhört frei zu drehen
ok ist fest jo gut ich mach mal an mal gucken was
jetzt passiert ne der sollte jetzt kogas mäßig sich drehen ich muss jetzt mal
hören auf einem ohr ob der sich ausschaltet
ja der hat sich ausgeschaltet es hat gemacht klick also benutzt bei
ebay reinstellen aber die andere richtung geht da nicht mehr
es hat auf jeden fall klick gemacht dass er am ende ist
sollte es jetzt nicht eigentlich in die andere richtung drehen
also es hat gemacht klick und er ist ausgegangen
welcher pose ist denn der jetzt der ist in der pose dass er hinten jetzt bei
meinem switch ausgeschaltet hat
so aber warum geht das jetzt nicht in die andere richtung
vielleicht doch falsch rum vielleicht doch falsch rum
drück mal den knopf erst mal gucken ob das der esp noch funktioniert
ja also knopf funkt
ich muss mal kurz hören ob ich also ich spiele mir ein man hört man hört
den relay klicken ich meine aber in die andere richtung drehen
sollte er sich schon auch noch was könnte das denn jetzt verhindern dass er sich in
die andere richtung dreht jetzt wird er auch überhaupt nicht warm der motor gibt es noch
andere vorlagen wir haben gar keine vorlage genommen
ich schraube jetzt gerade noch mal hier wieder fest ich habe keine vorlage genommen ich
habe das selbst eingestellt aber es funktioniert ja auch
denke ich zumindest
ich vertausche die ich vertausche die kabel nochmal
ich muss noch mal hören was passiert wenn ich hier einschalte
ja wunderbar ich vertausche das ich vertausche die dinger noch mal
na komm her
jetzt haben wir es mal woanders rum aber jetzt geht es jetzt geht auch der button
schon nicht
ne das war schon richtig also zumindest zumindest der button war
richtig ob das relay richtig ist
was jetzt warum schaltet er sich aus zwischendurch
also verkabelung zumindest für die led war die verkabelung richtig
so jetzt haben wir die led richtig dran aber warum geht denn der jetzt also wackelkontakt
ist jetzt sehe ich jetzt hier eigentlich nicht ich meine das ist ziemlich ziemlich ordentlich
dran alles
so ein bisschen drehen
hier 3,3 volt ja round alles richtig
jetzt geht es was ist das denn was kann das jetzt für einen einfluss darauf haben dass
der nicht startet das leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein
jetzt geht auch der button wieder nicht mehr
was kann das denn sein
endposition erreicht was soll die endposition denn warum sollte die endposition dem controller
das ist ein wlan ding den strom abschalten das ergibt keinen sinn
zu meiner witziger weise ja sogar angeht
ich muss gerade noch mal messen
muss es gerade noch mal kurz nachmessen
was haben wir denn hier jetzt
das ist verheddert ich gebe dir header alter
2,2 damit sollte der booten damit sollte der eigentlich booten
jetzt sollte der booten ohne ohne wenn und aber
der blinkt auch
ja ich verstehe nicht warum was das mit dem motor zu tun hat
ganz ehrlich keine ahnung zumal der motor ja sogar in der richtigen posi ist
der motor wird ja auch nicht warm oder so das ist alles richtig jetzt
der steht auch auf 3,3 ok ich habe keine ahnung warum der jetzt nicht bootet
deshalb verstehe ich nicht
ich sehe dass der angeht das ist ja das ding
ich sehe dass der angeht
habt ihr jetzt auch gerade gesehen
der bootet ja also was ob der bootet keine ahnung er geht auf jeden fall an
der crown ist ziemlich wackelig
der crown pin ist tatsächlich ziemlich wackelig
der so wackelig das löten wir nochmal kurz nach
das schauen wir mal vielleicht haben wir glück und es liegt wirklich daran dass der crown
pin nicht richtig dran ist
muss mir das mal ein bisschen hinrücken dass ich was sehe
die ganzen müll hier vorne ab
ich habe keinen platz
das hält nicht richtig was ist denn das jetzt
warum hält vor allem ich habe halt null ich mache mal ein bisschen größer
ich habe halt null
platz und ich sehe nichts wegen dem scheiß ring light
mache jetzt mal ein neues lutzchen drauf
das ist kacke so wie es ist
so wo habe ich wo ist es da
ihr seht ich weiß dass ihr nichts seht ich kann euch mal gucken dass ich vielleicht ein
bisschen
hin
aber ich sehe so ich sehe auch nichts
hier noch ein bisschen ohne dran
ja auf meine güte
habe hier keinen platz
ok schauen wir mal
putzen ein bisschen
ist das denn
btf warum hält das net was ist das für ein pet
monka es
ok jetzt lasse ich mal so und gucke ob es angeht
ich habe die ganze zeit den strom dran ist keine so gute idee das vielleicht keine so
gute idee daran rumzulöten mehr an strom alles
guck ob wir es kaputt gemacht haben
und mal gucken ob es mal gucken ob es dead ist
ne geht noch geht noch
also leute ich habe keine ahnung warum das ding nicht antwortet müsste erbootet theoretisch
es blinkt aber da mag nicht
was auch immer das mit dem motor zu tun hat dass es nicht ich habe keine ahnung
weiß echt nicht was mit dem china ding ist ich glaube das ist ich glaube das war von
Anfang an defekt ehrlich gesagt
der müsste jetzt booten ich sehe ja dass die led leuchtet
also vielleicht kommt da nicht genug genug spanung oder so keine ahnung
aber der motor ist geblockt der motor wird nicht warm
also es gibt keinen grund nicht anzugehen ich weiß es nicht leute ich gehe oft wir
sehen uns bis denn
z.